okay we're doing must have fun so what
is this fourth column represent well
it's the frequency multiplied by how
many visits that number of people have
right so if I add up all of these things
in this home video then down the bottom
would you agree that that's the same as
taking all of these and just adding them
up one by one is that you can write down
the tubes and all the three and then
although I've done everything yeah
thumbs up so come back to your table how
do I add things up again I've told you a
formula to do this equals sum open your
bracket and then you can highlight all
the cells which one so I'll leave that
there for a second so you can see what
it looks like if you'd like you don't
even need to have a Mickey Mouse you can
actually just go ahead Tim directly type
c2 to come up
c7 that means from c2 all the way to C
so all the way up and down can't press
ENTER now yep okay sure yeah let's have
a look at these I'm even gonna highlight
these two numbers in red maybe you want
to do the same how do I use these two
numbers to calculate the mate what I do
this is the total what happens when you
add up every single end of it what do
you do with them to get the baby / by
however many people have not which
mortgage that which is 34 so we can go
ahead we can divide that you know how
there's no multiplication table
but the amounts in one notebook they
aren't such as if the slash it's the one
that's closer to the spacebot down here
so I'm going to tap 71 conformity /
today for you could actually write
equals 70 1 / 34 but you might as well
just use the nom instead of it okay so
see that in top I get pissed on let's go
ahead and we can write that down water
[Music]
alright so you probably have more
decimal places because and this actually
went well yeah you're like why I have so
few decimal places well you might notice
the difference in you and me is that I
predict you the screen so I've made my
numbers all comically large so that
everyone in that row can see so as a
consequence how many digits can fit
inside my box you by coming into my kid
I'm really fit for right but if I make
myself in a wide you can see I've got
more decimal places Excel would just
like them if you can't fit that make
sense I we've just kept today the boat
company the mean the mean which is great
I asked you haven't media right now just
to remember if you have for example
seven different people okay and they
were already in port forward like say hi
board up or age orders and doing that
how do I work out with the meeting is
what I do to do this to people
yeah the middle sit for example I know a
way that I used to get talk was cross up
one from each side
yeah like so I'm so eventually you know
you can't cross off anymore oh that
person is the middle right so wait what
if there's two what if there is two
great question 1 2 3 3 4 5 6 7 8 so if I
tried this right
I would going across the cross cross
cross cross cross and then I'm like oh
what do i do me does anyone remember
what happens when you have
that's him yeah that's right so if I go
to in the middle neither of those is the
middle person so I say well what would
be in the middle of those two bill
people right so if this was on five and
six I'd say five and a half okay all
right now have a look we've got these
two situations you've got an odd number
of people you'll have exactly one person
in the middle if you've got an even
number of people it's going to be the
average of which of these situations in
aldana
which should be situations MIT at law or
even one two three four five always
before because that's its highest right
haven't think about it is there a way
without my doing $34 don't look up who
should be the middle - 34 / - a chick
was
like yes from Louis okay so let's let's
think about this right let's try and
number one by the way I'm going to try
and do this in a way that doesn't
require me to write out all of these
numbers because it's bad enough for $34
what if I have three hundred and $40 or
three thousand four hundred ohms I don't
what is that is a really really slow way
to do it I'm on frequency testing and
help us okay tell you back let's think
about how this would work as a
suggestion was divided by true you got
enough all right
well he's eight people if I divide by
two again if I'm not useful right and
sure enough there's the fourth and the
fifth people so in this case I got 17 so
my median should be average between
which two people 17 and 18 person 70
person 18 can work out having to write 0
0 0 0 0 1 1 1 1
we now have you tried a ball out can I
work out where the 17th and 18th of I
can't cause I have a look for example if
you went in a big person you should know
how many times it means the doctor
persisted so dr. C returns right the
next six people along so if I get to be
11th person 11th person
have you tried to basing it off once
right now I need to count past the 11th
person through the 17th
eighteen people can you see where
they're going to be but it's going to be
in Kia effect right so from there I
could say the N equals two now what's
nice about this is you've got the moment
lead and media all fairly close together
I do agree that they're all fairly close
together why is it that they're all so
close together like in these case
they're identical yeah it's just a giant
map choose which kind of skew everything
that way watch this this is most
beautiful have you done this in Excel
I've just got to go 8-8 right there
let's just suppose there was someone and
they really I don't know they just
wanted to they love the doctor they're
like my my doctor is my friend right so
they decided to see the doctor
don't make times in a month let's say 80
times I'm just going to type that right
and the beauty of having written all
these folders is by pressing enter now
did you see what just happened
do you love this match mine see how this
80
what's a diamond heat into an ATR so
what's like you mean how many people but
this person ask you a quick question how
is the mode change as the mode change
the mode is what most you Domitian use
most frequent was common right which is
the most common it's still the two so
the mode is a check
whatever meeting yeah I mean it is still
the the 17th and 18th people do you
agree yeah so there's still in here that
make sense so it just so happens that
we've got nice numbers so that's like
everything hangs together